l'assomption varennes rivière beaudette
rosemère val-alain brossard autant de
carambolages et l'hiver n'est pas
terminé
des experts en sécurité routière
soutiennent que ce type d'accident
pourraient être évités entre autres si
les automobilistes d'adapter leur
conduite
je suis capable de trouver la couche
d'autres comme le directeur des travaux
publics de l'ancienne lorette près de
québec croit que les entrepreneurs en
déneigement ont aussi un rôle à jouer au
niveau du jeu justement du verglas
on a des températures des soubresauts
qui fait que aujourd'hui peut faire 5
degrés dans la nuit on tombe à -15 qu'il
faut que les entrepreneurs sont
proactifs en servant des outils de
gestion puis les écrans radar seulement
il vient d'ailleurs de se doter de
nouveaux types de véhicules
c'est des outils qui nous servent à
plusieurs
sosa creps à transport de la neige ça et
pas du matériel pour les rues pour le
trottoir ce spécialiste suggère quant à
lui d'installer davantage de stations
météo pour suivre en temps réel
l'évolution du climat
une meilleure identification des
secteurs problématiques permettrait de
trouver une solution appropriée pour
chacun d'entre eux signalisation
différentes réduction de la vitesse
lorsque les conditions sont difficiles
sont aussi proposés il ya également le
brisement ça peut être des plantations
naturel et aussi des aménagements qui
peuvent se mettre plus rapidement comme
par exemple des clôtures à neige avec
une certaine c'est sûr que c'est pas
tout à fait la même efficacité
puis il ya également des barrières en
neige les ministères des transports du
québec et est actuellement de nouvelles
techniques de déneigement et de
déglaçage
parmi elles un pont autour des glaces en
sur l'autoroute 73 en beauce ou encore
des camions munis de lampes pouvant
s'adapter aux variations de la chaussée
mais comme il n'existe pas de solution
miracle
la règle la plus sage demeure toujours
de ne pas prendre la route lors des
tempêtes ici marie laurence de l'année
radio canada montréal